good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i am proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021-2022
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
we enjoy presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers with about the promise opportunities
and hurdles which are associated with ai
applications in the biomedical sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program
will have will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held here
in historic charlottesville virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data science
innovation lab program are being accepted until
january 31st 2022 so please consider applying
or encouraging your junior colleagues to do so
we will look forward to reviewing their materials
today it is my honor and my privilege to welcome
our speaker dr jarrett zigon from the university
of virginia dr zigon is the porter field chair of
bioethics and professor of anthropology here
at uva he is the former founding director of
the center for data ethics and justice at uva
he received his m.a in liberal arts from st
john's college and a phd in anthropology from the
city university of new york he subsequently was a
member of the institute for advanced study
at princeton university a visiting scholar
at columbia university and a research fellow at
the max planck institute for social anthropology
excuse me his lab has been funded through a
fulbright hayes fellowship and netherlands
organization for scientific research award and the
european research council among many other sources
his interests include ethical theory problematics
of being human the political ontological uh
oncological uh relationality and thinking anthropo
anthropologically um about things in philosophy
these interests are explored in his most recent
book disappointment towards a critical hermeneut
of world building and a war on people drug
user policy and a new ethics of community
in continuing this year's theme on biomedical
data science uh dr uh zigon's lecture today
is entitled on the necessity of relational
ethics and empathic attunement for data centric
technologies in his talk he will make a critical
phenomenological response to the ethical demand
that ai be sensitive to its varied sources of bias
by arguing for what he terms as relational ethics
in contrast to the dominant data ethical arguments
that call for the delineation of principles
or rules he will argue that only data centric
technologies are capable of empathic attunement
which can legitimately be called ethical machines
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you are watching on
youtube thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are strongly encouraged to submit any questions
for jarrett via the chat feature in their zoom
sessions i will synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or
so of the lecture and with that welcome jared
we are super excited to hear from you today
thank you jack
it's a real pleasure to be here i'd like to talk
today about ethics and data centric technologies
but before i do i just wanted to offer a bit of a
warning i'm not a data scientist nor an engineer
i don't code and honestly i more or less
use my computer as little more than a very
fancy typewriter i am going to be frank simply a
theorist who on occasion humbly attempts to think
about our contemporary condition of existence
and how we try to live within it so my talk today
will be a theoretical intervention in the emerging
ethical concerns around data centric technologies
put simply this is a theory paper i will leave
the practice to those who are able to do that
and hope that they are inspired in their work in
what i say here today most of my talk is extracted
from an article called can machines be ethical
that i published about a year ago in the journal
social research so you're welcome to go to that
journal and and and have a look to begin today
though i will briefly make some superficial
distinctions of how ethics is generally talked
about in relation to data centric practices and
technologies then i will continue by clarifying
what i mean by ethics as relational ethics
and finally i will provide an example that i
hope illustrates that a relational ethics more
appropriately responds to the ethical concerns
many have today about data centric
technologies and my less than hopeful
outlook on the possibility of its
implementation so let's get started
ethics is a growing concern in the realm
of data sciences artificial intelligence
and data centric technologies in general there
are good reasons for this we are all familiar
with concerns over such issues as data privacy
or data-driven surveillance or the increased
intertwining of the data industry with the
finance industry or the so-called defense industry
we are all familiar with the fact that
data extracting and data-driven algorithms
increasingly regulate the temporal affective
and inter-subjective modalities of everyday life
and we are all familiar with how this
regulation along with the sometimes
over the top but sometimes legitimate concerns of
how ai may change the very definition of the human
as well as life itself is increasingly not
only of ethical but existential concern
indeed there are good reasons why we are
experiencing what i would call an ethical
demand made by this data-centric situation we
now find ourselves in unfortunately at least in
my view the response to this ethical demand by
most data-centric practitioners and ethicists
is overwhelmingly framed in terms of principles
guidelines rules and ultimately law and policy
this response has taken various forms some for
example have called for increased ethical policing
of data science research which might take the form
of institutional review board oversight others
consider it vital that data scientists themselves
receive some form of ethical training to help
combat for example blindness to both their own and
structural biases that might enframe their work or
to help combat what is now seen as the widespread
transgressions of data-centric industries finally
some have argued that data centric technologies
themselves such as artificial intelligence
must be built with ethical capacities to help
guide their inevitable shaping of human worlds
these are all reasonable and perhaps even
necessary responses unfortunately however and
true to the instrumentalist reasoning that guides
so many data centric practitioners ethics in each
of these various forms tends to be conceived in
terms of what i call either the checklist or rule
book approach to ethics what i call the checklist
approach considers a practice ethical if and only
if certain predefined principles can be checked
off a pre-established list of such principles
does a certain algorithmic practice respect
the principle of privacy yes good check ethical
that in essence is the principle based or
checklist approach to ethics in action similarly
the rulebook approach considers a practice ethical
if and only if pre-articulated rules are followed
have you guarded against the re-identification
of your data yes good rule followed ethical
that in essence is the rule-based or
rule book approach to ethics in action
while these two approaches may be useful
in certain institutional or bureaucratic
contexts for protection against litigation
or ethical research compliance for example
i argue they have nothing to do with ethics as a
human practice and the cultivated sensibilities
necessary to be and become an ethical person
therefore while the checklist and rule book
approaches may be useful for example in the very
narrow concern of irb research approval or the
prevention of litigation it is the wrong road
to take if one were interested in for example
developing ethical persons who are also data
scientists or as i will focus on in the rest
of this talk developing ethical data center
technologies such as artificial intelligence
in order to clarify this i will take a brief
detour to consider an early and important
critique of artificial intelligence in
1965 the phenomenologist hubert dreyfus
published a critical essay entitled alchemy
and artificial intelligence which was later
expanded into the book what computers can't
do in short dreyfus was critical of the then
dominant approach in artificial intelligence
research that assumed that human intelligence
is a matter of the mental representation of facts
and the abstraction and interiorization of rules
and as such researchers assumed that artificial
intelligence could be achieved through programmed
rules and the representation of facts this is
a symbolic information processing model of ai
or symbolic a.i dreifus predicted rightly it
now seems that such an approach would fail
as it began from the faulty cartesian assumption
of representationalism in contrast to this
cartesian approach to intelligence dreyfus
argued for an embodied and phenomenological
approach to intelligence building on the work
of both martin heidegger and maurice marlo ponti
dreyfus considered intelligence as primarily a
consequence of our embodied and involved ongoing
activity in situations in the world through which
over time we come to acquire not only background
common sense understanding or intelligence but
also all the interests feelings motivations and
bodily capacities that go to make a human being
as such intelligence is a matter of an acquired
and skilled habit that is continuously maintained
and developed by means of a kind of situationally
sensitive feedback loop in response to ongoing
and altering situations such embodied intelligence
stripis argued could never be represented by
data structures made up of facts and rules
as he went on to put it if the body turns out
to be indispensable for intelligent behavior
then we shall have to ask whether the body can be
simulated on a heuristically programmed digital
computer if not then the project of artificial
intelligence is doomed from the start at the
time dreyfus's intervention was contemptuously
and publicly dismissed by most in the artificial
intelligence community but privately many took it
seriously and considered how to adopt his insights
today things have changed it seems rather obvious
that the contemporary successes of data-centric
machine learning are at least in part a matter
of these new technologies mimicking in some ways
the phenomenological approach to
intelligence that dreyfus argued for
in his updated version of the
book what computers still can't do
dreyfus acknowledges that data centric ai and he
particularly focuses on neural networks has made
some progress in this direction and more recently
he seems to have accepted that neural networks
have to a great extent satisfy the requirements
of this phenomenological approach to intelligence
founded on a kind of feedback adjustment between
mind and world importantly however dreyfus argues
that the problem of generalization a key element
for intelligence cannot be solved without cannot
be solved with a disembodied neural network though
it does indicate that a neural in that robot with
a body may be able to solve this problem for now
however i will set this aside for the extent to
which dreyfus is correct in his analysis or
prediction is beyond the scope of this talk
what you may ask does this have to do with
ethics and what follows i would like to
begin to convince you that contemporary concerns
with developing ethical data center technology
should make a similar shift in approach to a
phenomenological and relational notion of ethics
the first point to make is this the checklist and
rule book approaches to ethics those approaches
that speak in terms of principles guidelines and
rules are analogous to the symbolic ai approach to
intelligence of programming rules and representing
facts just as the ai community has learned
hopefully at least that intelligence and practice
is not a matter of symbolic representation
so too it must learn that ethics and practice
is not a matter of following rules or adhering
to principles to put it bluntly ethics cannot
be pre-programmed as a set of rules or as a
list of principles this approach outside
of a few institutional and bureaucratic
concerns is a dead end how then can we conceive of
ethics in a phenomenological and relational manner
to begin to answer this in the next
section i will articulate in broad strokes
what i call relational ethics before in the
final section turning to a specific example
of the ethical failure of a data centric
technology to illustrate the importance of
relational ethics not only for the future of
such technologies but for social life as such
for the next several minutes i will
indulge in a bit of philosophizing
so i ask your patients i hope though that
it will prove helpful as we move forward
perhaps the most fundamental of
all ethical questions is to ask
how is it between us such a seemingly simple
question is immediately differentiable for more
commonly asked ethical questions such as what
is the good or did she act rightly and in this
differentiation its radicality is revealed when
we ask what is the good or did she act rightly
there is an assumption built into these questions
that there is a the good the wetness of which we
can we can query or an exact rightness that
can come to modify precisely a particular act
when we ask these questions we assume the
prior existence of the good or the right
already there as the object or the measure
in reference to which the questions could be
answered definitively oftentimes the good or the
right are articulated in terms of rules principles
guidelines and laws the pre-establishment of
which stand available as that against which we
can measure our ethical adequacy is it possible to
conceive of ethics without the good or the right
always already there to measure up to the
standard by which any possible ethics is judged
in the rest of this section i will respond to
this question in the affirmative and begin to
offer in broad strokes an outline for what i call
relational ethics as that which offers a response
to the query of how it is between us the work of
the philosopher immanuel lebinos is vital here
in contrast to all of those ethical
theories that make the ontological
assumption that human subjects exist as
ethical subjects with some sort of a priori
built-in capacity to act ethically for example
to be rule followers or moral calculators
or autonomous law givers and adherents lebinos
argues that the ethical subject is constituted
through what he calls the other what does this
mean allow me to oversimplify the other always
exceeds any idea that i may have of that other
for example in terms of what and who the other is
what the other desires or even how i should
act with and toward the other and loving us
names this phenomenon of the excess of the
other infinity because i and the other are
always intertwined in this infinite relationality
as an ethical subject i must give myself over
or open myself to the unknowable and
incomprehensible difference that is the other
therefore and in contrast to reducing the other
to comprehensibility through a proceduralist act
i have what levines calls infinite responsibility
to the other perhaps more appropriately rendered
i must respond to the call or demand of the
other or alternatively i must attune to the other
momentarily i will return to this concept of
responsivity and show how lebinos considers
the form of conversation as the structure
of this attuned response for leaving us not
only the possibility of ethics but the very
possibility that i become an ethical subject
begins with the other this formal structure
of the condition of possibility for ethics
and the ethical subject is what lebanese calls
transcendence this notion of transcendence does
not establish a radical dichotomy between
ordinary everyday life and some realm beyond
and it does not necessitate religion or some other
sphere of values neither it should be noted does
levinoxian transcendence indicate an imminent
urge to transcend any given option toward its
presumably better state or alternative rather
it simply expresses the relational structure
of ordinary everyday existence or as lebinos puts
it the ecstatic relationality of transcendence
delineates the structure of exteriority and
thus makes possible the pluralism of society
perhaps the ordinariness of relation
of this relationality is best revealed
but lebinos's insistence that it begins in the
bodily materiality of the face of the other
confronted by the enigma of the face of the
other i must respond i must attune when this
attunement does not occur in a smooth fashion the
enigma of the other makes an ethical demand on me
the experience of which is what i have called a
moral breakdown far from the mischaracterization
of the rupturing of the everyday made by those
who have critiqued this concept of moral breakdown
the experience of a moral breakdown is in fact
more intensely felt and considered relational
intertwining with others and this relationality is
more intensely felt and considered in the moment
of breakdown precisely because the demand of the
other has explicitly called me to ethically attune
in the next section i will consider more closely
how this attunement as empathic attunement
is the very condition of possibility for ethics
despite the significance of this relational
structure for considering ethics i have argued
elsewhere that the asymmetry that levinas posits
falls short of the kind of mutuality of beings
some of us might prefer to consider if for loving
us the other is separated from me by what he
calls an infinite curvature of intersubjectivity
then my task is to conceive of this asymmetrical
relation in more mutual terms without reducing
this mutuality to a totalized co-relational
pseudo-relation that is our question might be
posed as this how to maintain the enigma of the
other and the asymmetrical relation this entails
while at the same time recognizing
that the other must also relate to me
as an enigmatic other put another way how can we
conceive mutuality without reducing this relation
to a totality of the same i will begin to address
these questions by turning to what i call between
how is it between us in contrast to asking the
op priority question indicated by the what or
did a question that begins with the assumption
that ethics is an accomplishment of a telos or
acting according to a predefined measure to ask
how is to ask about an ongoing process imminent to
situations within which we find ourselves to ask
how is to understand ethics as ongoing attunement
who attunes us in contrast to the individual
who aims for the good or attempts to act rightly
and in contrast to a we that is a totalized
or categorized plurality the us that attunes
is the non-categorizable plurality of singular
beings that are neither individuals nor merely
a part of a collective but unique instances
of being relational put in lebanosian terms
the non-categorizable us is
indicative of a relational ontology
that entails that the other is always infinitely
other to me as well as other possible others
how is it between us this ongoing attunement
imminent to worlds and situations is indicative of
the ecstatic revelationality that gives way to us
the place of this giving way i will name between
but do so with the caveat that this between that
is relationality neither can be objectified thing
like nor spatialized through this nomination
and yet this between the relationality emerges
how phenomenological analysis would disclose
multiple responses to this question but given
the limitations of this talk today as well as
its clear resonance with many ethical concerns
raised by data-centric technologies i will focus
on one possible response and that is language
the phenomenological hermeneutic
conception of language is helpful here
a good starting point for understanding
an important version of this is martin
heidegger's claim that language is the house
of being what could such an enigmatic phrase
mean when he wrote this he immediately followed
it with this quote in it in its home man dwells
dwell on language and do so as existing for
heidegger as it is for much of this tradition
to exist is to be ecstatic always to be outside
oneself intertwined with other ecstatic beings
human and non-human alike for humans language
is one of the primary entanglements of this
relationality thus it is to a great extent through
language that humans are pulled beyond themselves
to dwell in between with others notice this
phenomenon is a pulling and not a projecting
unlike those conceptions of language that
begin with a view of language grounded in a
prior and already established set of criteria or
grammar that is projected out from the individual
speaker a phenomenological view of language
sees language as a primary effective force
emanating from between us that pulls and places
demands on us to respond the manifold responses
which manifest more as listening than speaking
enliven the between by means of their distinction
thus in contrast to the projection of
an assumed shared criteria or grammar
a projection that levinox considered to be an
act of violence the distinctive and manifold
responses to the call of language give way to a
between characterized above all by difference a
difference that is to which attunement is ongoing
this is simply another way of describing ethics
hydra can heidegger contrasted this view of
language with more common conceptions of language
which as he put it is the notion that language
is the expression produced by humans of their
feelings and the worldview that guides them as he
went on to claim this is a notion of language from
which we must become liberated this is the notion
that assumes not only that language is structured
by a set of shared criteria and grammar but also
can express a shared meaning elsewhere i have
argued against the anthropological focus on shared
meaning and have tried to make the case that at
least in ethical encounters although i presume
this is indeed the case with most encounters
language does not express shared
meaning but rather acts as what i call
a bridge of being that is to say ethics is
ongoing attunement is not about adhering to a
pre-established criteria or grammar and neither is
it about finding the spot of shared meaning rather
the extent that language is a modality of ethical
attunement it is that call that demand that pull
that allows the possibility to dwell once
again again with others in the world between us
language as a modality of ethics
then calls us places a demand on us
to be with others in the world in an attuned
manner letting us vote of this phenomenon as
for loving us language is the relation
between the same and the other
which is just a fancy philosophical way of saying
me and you whoever the me and the you might be
ethically this relation takes the form of
conversation here it is important to emphasize
that loving us is not arguing that the actual act
of conversation is ethics though at times it may
be but rather that the form of conversation can
be understood as the formal structure of ethics
what does this mean in conversation lavinas writes
we become astonished through conversation with the
other the other through conversation the other is
revealed in her strangeness to me i can never know
prior to the other speaking what she will say
and as such i must listen and then respond
but i cannot respond with a projection my
response cannot be a claim of knowing the other
and neither can it be a taking over
the conversational relation with the
claim that for example ah yes the same thing
happened to me because the same thing never
happens such a claim is not a continuance of
open conversation but rather shuts it down
through the colonization of the other by me in
conversation the other is revealed is not the same
which means that she cannot be thematized through
a projection of an all priori criteria or grammar
or the claim of a shared experience or the
fitting into some preconceived principle or rule
rather to be in conversation is to let the other
be and then attune as such relational ethics
encounters the alternative of the other through
a tuned letting be that preserves the between of
difference if as the anthropological linguist
eleanor oaks has written ordinary enactments
of language are modes of experiencing the world
this can only be so because worlds and situations
are already partly constituted through language
constituted not as i've been trying to argue as
worlds in situations of a projected shared meaning
or a shared form of life but rather as the between
that pulls us together in our differences in
the modalities of concern and content care
how is it between us this is perhaps the
most fundamental of all ethical questions
because as humans we can only live together in
worlds and situations as intertwined in a between
that is all we can ever share it is for this
reason that the philosopher hannah arndt argued
that we are concerned and cared for the between
because we have an interest in its being for the
between is essential to the human condition we are
concerned and care in our interest in our interest
that is in our being between as being
relational if in 1958 hannah arndt could
limit the between to the human condition in
the 21st century that is no longer possible
today such phenomena is climate change and the
colonization of everyday life by data center
technologies has made it abundantly clear that the
between is essential to the existential condition
the between can no longer be limited to between
you and me but must be the between of existence
and yet the manner in which the human responds
to the call of this existential between will
be decisive do we continue to project our already
established rules and principles onto the between
or do we let be and attune if how is it between
us is the most fundamental question then how we
respond to it must be the most fundamental
of ethical as well as existential replies
i have just articulated in broad strokes a
relational ethics that begins from the fact that
humans are primarily beings who are relationally
intertwined with others in specific situations
and that what counts as ethics in our everyday
lives is not a matter of adhering to a checklist
of principles or following a rule book but
rather responding and attuning to situationally
unique demands placed upon us in
the ongoing vicissitudes of life
in this sense ethics is not a matter of deciding
between a number of predetermined options
but rather in each instance entails a
singular response to this situation now
such a response takes the form of an attunement
not only to the singularity of the situation
but to the singularity of the other or others
there with you and to do so in the modality
of letting be and care in the rest of my talk i
will illustrate the importance of this notion of
relational ethics for considering the possibility
of ethical and data centric technologies
and most importantly their relational
intertwining in our everyday lives
consider the tragic case of mark hemmons as
recounted by john jamie lippeld in his book
we are data this is a quote from
the book it's 2013 and mark hemmings
a 41 year old british disabled man dials the
number for emergency services in the uk 999
an operator answers and hemmings immediately makes
his condition known my stomach is an agony duck
i've got lumps in my stomach the operator
responds with the first of many inquiries
have you got any other symptoms hemming replies
i'm in agony sweating a lot feeling weak
going on mostly all day the operator asks more
questions have you had any diarrhea or vomiting
have you ever been diagnosed with an aortic
aneurysm or marfan syndrome have you got any
crushing or aching pain in your upper abdomen
through the agony hemmings diligently puts
hemings diligently but excruciatingly answers them
all he requests in the ambulance three separate
times he also explains his pain and description
and accompanying tone as agonizing a heartbreaking
seven times at the end of the call the operator
concludes from what you've told me you don't
require an emergency ambulance but we will get
somebody to call you back 90 minutes later a
general practitioner did call mr hemmings and
recognize that he needed to be seen immediately
still he refused to make a house call and
told mr hemmings to take an ambulance instead
mr hemmings told the gp that he had been refused
an ambulance nevertheless and not taking this
important information into account the gp still
insisted that mr hemmings come into the hospital
and made an appointment for him when mr
hemmings did not show for the appointment
his records were marked as did not attend two days
later mr hemmings was discovered by an in-house
healthcare worker unconscious in his home and died
minutes after having been rushed to the hospital
mr hemmings died of a heart attack brought on by
gallstones blocking his pancreatic duct a routine
operation would have saved his life if he had been
correctly diagnosed and brought to the hospital
although the official cause
of death was heart attack
it is perhaps more accurate to say that the tragic
case of mr hemings is one of death by algorithm
but the questions asked by
the operator were not her own
nor were they read from some template but rather
came directly from an algorithmic triage system
the human operator simply acted as the
mouthpiece the voice of the algorithm
what can we learn from this tragic case the most
obvious takeaway is that an ethical relation is
not simply a matter of input and output although
relational ethics is as i argued in the previous
section an ongoing process of responsibility or
attunement is not simply a feedback mechanism
mr hemmings provided all of the input he was asked
to but the output was not ethically adequate to
his situation neither obviously was it medically
adequate but i will set aside that disturbing fact
i should note that almost certainly a linear
algorithmic triage system was used in this case
which has an essential task ensuring that certain
rules are followed thus it would be inappropriate
to expect that it could attune to the singularity
of mr heming's ethical demand for care
as no delineated rules ethical or otherwise
could allow for attunement input of this
nature is simply illegible to such an algorithmic
system some argue that a non-linear triage system
based on machine learning and other artificial
intelligence elements would have the capacity
to respond to the singularity of individual
medical needs this may be so and yet this does
not entail that such a system would be any better
responding to the singularity of ethical demands
for ethical demands are not a matter of providing
more data and ethical responses are not a matter
of adjusting parameters to increase data
let's be clear the ethical demand made by mr
hemmings in his 999 call was not for the most part
articulated through his factual description of his
symptoms but rather by means of his interjected
affective utterances sounds and tone
that infuses answers to the algorithmic questions
mr hemmings did not simply provide facts but more
importantly was making an ethical demand on
another mr hemming's ethical demand is not made
in his description of his bowel movements but
rather when he several times says i'm in agony
or asks if we could have an ambulance and
speaks the entire time in an agonizing tone
with interspersed sounds that indicate severe
pain suffering and the vulnerable need for care
in other words mr heming's ethical demand
is not made through the articulation of
facts read as data that may or may not fit the
measurable type of deserving emergency treatment
rather his ethical demand is made as an
affective force and as such the other to
whom this demand is made must be able to
recognize it as such and respond as called
such recognition and response are a matter of what
the anthropologist jason troupe calls empathic
attunement and not simply a matter of input output
adjustments for troop empathic attunement is that
human capacity that allows one to imagine
what the experience of another could be like
importantly such empathic attunement is a
relational matter in that not only does the
other participate in my empathic achievement with
her but she is simultaneously attuning with me
an attunement that i too participate in we
might describe this as reciprocal attunement
in this sense empathic attunement and the
imaginative process it entails allows for the
essential intertwining of being human together in
other words empathic attunement is essential not
just to ethics but the sociality as such this is
a key insight from the phenomenological tradition
in the way in which empathy has been articulated
within it thus for example the phenomenologist
dan sahabi has written that empathy is the
term of choice for phenomenologists for
the experience of foreign consciousness it is a
distinctive form of other directed intentionality
distinct from both self-awareness and ordinary
object intentionality which allows foreign
experiences to disclose themselves as foreign
rather than his own it is important here to note
that empathy is that which allows difference
in alterity to emerge or become disclosed it
is that which allows for our recognition
of the infinite singularity of all others
rather than collapsing the other into a projection
of myself indeed the philosopher edith stein was
quite clear the infant empathy is a sui generous
form of intentionality directed at the other as
absolutely other in this way empathic attunement
is that which allows for the asymmetrical
and infinite relationality between oneself and
another that i described in the last section
and as the essence of relational ethics thus
as a sue daenerys other directed intentionality
empathy could be considered the very
condition of possibility for ethics
now i'd like to take up this concept of empathic
attunement in a radically relational manner
thus by empathic attunement i do not intend
the intersubjective coming to be connected
of two self-same individualized subjects
standing over and against one another as this
phenomenological articulation of empathy could
be but i think would be mistakenly read rather
by empathic attunement i mean becoming attuned
to always already having been intertwined with
other beings through the ecstatic relationalities
we essentially are thus one does not have empathy
for another over against the self but rather
empathic attunement is the attuned relationality
that constitutes what comes to be derivatively
experienced as for example a you and an i
that is and as i have already described empathic
attunement is that which allows for difference
empathic attunement then is the coming into
awareness of our essential relational being
as differentiated ecstatic relationality empathic
imagination is the coming into awareness by means
of this attunement of what it might be like
as an other within this relationality of being
empathic attunement and imagination conceived in
this radically relational manner is essential to
relational ethics for indicates that ethics is
not simply a relational response of an input
output adjustment based on facts but in attunement
to the affective and differential relationality
of intertwined existence similar to the way in
which the philosopher edmund husserl argued that
we always have a sense of the beingness of
that which we perceive as a result of what
he called a categorical intuition that is infused
in our relational consciousness of any particular
object so too i suggest our attuned relational
being is infused with an empathic intuition
that provides the very possibility for ethics to
put it simply without the capacity for empathic
attunement ethics is not possible mr hemmings
in his own way knew this well he needed medical
attention and sought it in the only way he could
because this was likely not the first time he had
dealt with the overly bureaucratic medical system
of the uk he seemed to understand that while he
needed to meet the strict bureaucratic standards
necessary to be offered care he should also add
an ethical appeal or demand to help persuade the
operator to send an ambulance if the bureaucracy
fails to recognize him perhaps the human would
he may have thought unfortunately for mr hemings
he was not speaking with another human but rather
the human articulation of an algorithmic system as
such an ethical demand could not be made by
mr hemmings because empathic attunement was
the much hyped human in the loop of normative
data ethicists was rendered in human by being
reduced to nothing more than the auditory
supplement of the algorithmic system
perhaps we could conceive of the operator as an
anthropo board for as the human in the loop she
simply became part of an input output factual
feedback system and not the guarantor of an
ethical outcome as normative data ethicists would
hope with the human in the loop rendered inhuman
mr hemings could not make an ethical demand
because there is no other being with whom he
could ethically and empathically attune and he
could and who could attune with him and return
if as dan sahabi has written i am pathetically
attuned to the other as a suspender of orientation
as a perspective on the world and as a result my
relation to the world will change since the other
will always be given to me in a situation where
meaningful context which points back to the other
as a new center of reference the meaning of
the world has for the other affects the meaning
it has for me then this simply cannot
happen with data centric technologies
current attempts to build what is
called emotional ai for example
will i suspect ultimately failed to live up to any
expectation from empathic attunement this is so
because such attempts are founded on the
assumption that data such as varying heart rate
the flutter of a micro facial expression the
sudden rise in skin conductance can serve as
measurable and machine-readable signs of affect
as long as data-centric technologies can only
recognize humans as just another object
in the world that is a source of data
extraction then it will never be able to
recognize a human as a perspective on the
world that is above all else a dependently
relational being without such recognition
recognition that emerges in excess of any amount
of available data ethical attunement is impossible
of course of course data centric technologies
can't do this one might proclaim an exasperation
but what of that operator doesn't she have a moral
obligation to step in and override the system
doesn't she have any principles it would be
too easy and i believe naive to level moral
condemnation on the operator for she like
mr hemmings was simply caught up in a larger
neoliberal bureaucratic assemblage that values
efficiency in the bottom line over care for others
be they human or otherwise and data-centric
technologies are just the latest tools for
achieving these values when efficiency and profit
are the primary values an instrumental reason is
the primary means of achieving them then all of
those caught up within the various manifestations
of this assemblage are too often rendered
incapable of the most basic human capacities
for ethically attuning with others in this sense
algorithmic artificial intelligent and other data
centric technologies are the latest dream
tool of neoliberal bureaucratic assemblages
of control and order that render ethics nearly
impossible as a result if not unlike the man
standing before the law in kafka's parable
mr hemings received no response ethically
or medically as he pleaded for both before the
cold logic of the algorithm and then he died
according to the diagnostic and statistical
manual of mental disorders fifth edition
anti-social personality disorder is characterized
by among other things a lack of empathy for others
often times exhibited in the process of
accomplishing an aim or desired outcome by almost
any means and without concern for how the outcome
affects others this disorder is more colloquially
known as sociopathy or psychopathy it may also
be the best description of the algorithmic triage
system described in the previous section and
perhaps all data center technologies in general
we should recall that the aim of
the of two of the participants
in turing's famous imitation game that is
the man in the machine was to deceive the
interrogator the aim of the third participant
the woman was to help the interrogator
putting aside the revealing gender assumptions
and dynamics that set the context of this game
we might like to note that thinking and remember
the question that guides the imitation game as can
machines think is more or less equated with the
ability to deceive another by means of strategic
lying and deception and without any concern for
the other and how he or she may feel about this
what turing identifies as thinking
psychology identifies as psychopaths
today the thinking machines that turing envisioned
exist and are increasingly folded into the texture
of our everyday lives such that when we ask
how is it between us we oftentimes must count
some form of data center technology is right
there with us if not disruptively between us
one response to this of course is to
continue the head in the stand approach
that has characterized much of the last decade
or so as these technologies have slowly and now
rapidly become a part of our worlds but in doing
so we must accept that we will surely see more and
more tragic cases like that of mr hemmings another
response would be that of the normative ethicists
and their principles and guidelines who
seem to think that ethics is little more
than adhering to the checklist or the rule book
or perhaps even a calculation this approach is
appealing to data-centric practitioners because it
matches well their instrumental view of the world
ethics in this view is just another
pre-programmable pre-programmable parameter
to solve a predefined problem unfortunately
ethical demands and the responses they call for
can never be pre-known or predetermined for ethics
to be ethics there cannot be any predetermined
mode of action and outcome ethics is not a
program it is a situationally attuned struggle
to decide despite the undecidability of the moment
as such ethical demands and responses can only be
recognized as they emerge in situ and responded
to in the best possible manner which in many cases
is simply a good enough manner as the singular
demand of this situation calls i've been trying
to show that because data center technologies
are and will increasingly become a significant
aspect of our worlds we need to recognize that
when we ask how it is between us how we reply
will be significantly determined by the way these
technologies respond to us there in the between
of our everyday worlds this is what i urge data
scientists and other so-called innovators and
builders of data-centric technologies to realize
just as artificial intelligence benefited greatly
from the phenomenological critiques leveled
against it by hubert dreifus and others
so too only phenomenological and relational ethics
can both adequately describe the responsibility
of ethics as well as offer a telos as it
were for which that responsibility aims
we may one day discover that it is
impossible to build data center technologies
such as artificial intelligence that are
capable of empathic and ethical attunement
but if we don't try and try in ways that go beyond
reading the human as a source of data extraction
then i'm afraid that our worlds will increasingly
be populated by psychopathic machines thank you
jared thank you that was fantastic i have
several questions as i was listening to you talk
and you made the comment of language is the
house of being and i thought a little bit about
language and where language kind of fits into
our biomedical research enterprise and probably
one of the most place most important places
where it comes in in the research enterprise
is in the relational ethics which involve informed
consent between a researcher or an investigator
and a research subject and very often
researchers refer to themselves in the
we we are doing this research we're very
august very highly accomplished people
we are our own unitary group whereas them
the research subjects are those people who
are going to come in and do our experiments
and and basically be data providers for us
flipping that around the research subjects may
have motivations for wanting to participate in
that experiment they may have expectations about
what they're going to get out of it if anything
likewise for the investigators and it's in that in
between that there is some degree of empathic um
attunement and i was just kind of curious
about how do we kind of overcome the tendency
to view informed consent and the ethics
involved with it as this kind of being pro
forma checklist-y kind of stuff how can
we actually take that more seriously and
understand that there's an attunement that
we need to achieve with our research subjects
so that we can one make them full participants
in our research and provide us with the kind of
data we can you know use effectively does that
make sense i hope so yeah i think so uh thanks
jack so that question's a little bit different
from what i was trying to argue in terms of
kind of how we build ethics into machines as
it were so i'm going to get to that in a minute
but but that but what you ask is certainly
important and so so on the one hand i want to say
that kind of the very model of informed consent
and and uh that often as part of for example um
irb institutional review board um research uh
approved research um in a sense this kind of
goes against or is counter to or outside of what
i've been trying to argue for in the sense that it
is um at least in my experience and as an
anthropologist who's done quite a bit of field
research um i've always had to have that research
pre-approved by irb but it's the irb model is kind
of this this kind of as i put it in the talk
this projection this this this predetermined
preconceived projection of of what the
relationship already will be and and the consensus
may be informed in the sense that the the
research participant is now made aware of what
how the research will unfold and they will be a
part of it but in most cases they have very little
say on how that research unfolds they just kind
of as it were consent to be folded into it right
to use the fancy language that i used a bit in the
talk it's it's a projection of the same onto the
other it's not it's not a kind of listening and
letting be to the other that that i respond to
as a researcher um and then kind of adjust along
the way um does that make any sense so yeah so
i think i think that sorry but i think the
goal here would be changing the very idea
of what an informed consent process would look
like such that it is a more mutual kind of um
to use a kind of language i would normally not use
a kind of negotiation but um but that might be in
maybe the easiest quickest way to put it that
that's that's interesting you also brought up
the experience of mr hemmings and you made the
comments of death by algorithm and any of us of
if you have lived long enough you start to run
into problems with relatives or loved ones who
are admitted to hospital and the nurse comes in
and she you know takes a blood pressure and asks
you know what's your pain level out of 10 you
know and the person says you know eight or nine
and then they walk the nurse walks out of the
room and you're like what was the point of that
and somebody who has that whether it's in it
from a computer or it's just how people are
trained to follow an algorithm this is what you
do i mean is this sort of the human equivalent
of an ai system being trained to recognize
images of dogs but being presented with the
image of a bird and not really knowing how
to change out of the algorithm is that fair
yeah and i think that's kind of the let's say the
limitation of this example that i gave is that
i recognize that that a lot of um practice in in
medical settings like like the one you just gave
um are in in some ways algorithmic already even
if it's not through a computer right um so um so
this is kind of a broader critical intervention
on on um uh health and medical contexts where
again there's needs to be get out of this um
algorithmic approach whether that's through a
computer or a template or just um the training
that that that uh professionals go through
um and you know and this is i'm certainly far from
the first person to to to talk about this but this
something that uh seems increasingly important now
that um that um these this algorithmic approach is
is is incredibly is even further out of the hands
of a human um than say just kind of that that that
template that's back at the nurse's station
or whatever you know if you know what i mean
yeah i mean i'm just thinking about how we try to
emulate those kind of interactions in a computer
system you know we're presented with an ipad
and you go through and you check some boxes
and you know it's essentially doing what a nurse
or you know medical professional might have done
um and they're following a routine an algorithm
a recipe and you know the recipe you know does
if you if you deviate from the recipe they isn't
sure what to do with that information which brings
me to my last question which is can any machine
or algorithm or you know pile of computer code
which as you claim may be psychopathic ever pass
a turing test if empathic attunement is a criteria
well
assuming that i understand the question and the
turing test correctly then i i would say that um
that one that is able to um exhibit that's the
right word um have empathic attunements um would
be the uh would would pass the turing test um
you know um with you know batteries flying colors
flying colors exactly with the highest
grade precisely precise that that person if
that is if the question is precisely you know
like is this a human or a machine i i think
that it's precisely the empathic attunement aspect
that makes us human and not the thinking aspect
yeah and that's what what really struck me is
as we're developing algorithms and we want them
almost in some instances to behave as if they're
human this empathic attunement adjusting to
the point of view of another having a theory
of mind if you will for what the other
maybe and what their motivations and their
expectations are without that a computer is
just going to be another another psychopath that
we have to contend with in a world full of them
anyway uh Jarrett thank you so very much this
was uh very thought-provoking um it has a lot
of relevance to the topic of how we're thinking
about ai applications what that really means uh as
you know as we embed this into health related
research health related practice um in medicine
and in our understanding of how we're going to
try and create you know smart health systems
and ai driven methodologies i really appreciate
you taking the time to chat with us today this
was super fun thank you so much thank you jack it
was really my pleasure everybody have a wonderful